all right congresswoman ocasio-cortez
remaining
silent and defiant tonight amid scrutiny
that she told a misleading story about
her experiences on january 6 during the
capitol hill violence
here's how she responded on cbs though
earlier this morning take a look
you know i think it's um it's it's
unfortunately kind of the the spring to
deny and to politicize our accounts
was something that that i sat with and
it was a big reason
why you know on top of making sure that
we could
clear our story due to security concerns
there's also a reason why i sat on that
on my story as well you know so many
survivors
fear being publicly doubted
now like i said we want to be fair was a
shocking
stressful experience one that can never
happen again
facts matter and the timeline of events
matter so
you know we can fully understand what
happened and make sure we protect our
institutions
make sure we protect every elected
official here's congresswoman nancy mace
who is just two doors down from aoc
last night she said this right here on
this program
it was a very harrowing experience but
we have to separate fact
from fiction and the facts are there
there was no violent mob
in the hallways the the folks who were
there to riot
weren't in the cannon office building
and so
we have to be very clear and not
exaggerate this experience
or take advantage of it and politicize
it in any way shape or form and that was
that was my entire point just to be
truthful about it
it's fascinating to watch the the shift
the excuse making the mob the media
continuing
to try and needlessly politicize this
not only the story
and use it though as a line of attack
against conservatives
fake news cnn host our friend don lemon
asking why this is even a story in the
first place
take a look i'm glad you said that
because i've been watching
you know state media and listening to
conservative media all day because i you
know i want to hear the other side
and i was like i don't understand why
this is a story i'm not
there's nothing to do with anything aoc
or whatever but how
i kept trying to figure out how the
people who were actually involved in
that siege
and all the chaos could be criticizing
someone else who was involved in it
because they were
because she was explaining how what she
thought was going on all right don
no one's claiming that congresswoman
ocasio-cortez should have known exactly
what was going on in the heat of the
moment
no one is trying to attack her she is
really in reality the speaker of the
house
pelosi speaker and name only we just
want the facts and as congresswoman may
said
oh well what ocasio-cortez had relayed
to the public
as i heard them screaming in the hall
and begging on the door where is she
where is she
and she said that account never happened
so we want to offer the proper context
and perspective it was a tragic day but
here with reaction fox news contributor
media reporter for the hill joe concha
along with fox and friends
weekend co-host pete hegseth joe nancy
mace is interesting she's not really a
big trump supporter
she's two doors down apparently nobody
was you know this is what anywhere
between 10 minutes away
from what was happening in the capitol
there were police outside to keep people
safe which i'm glad to hear
and but there was nobody in the hall
screaming and banging on the door where
is she where is she where is she as she
had claimed
uh your take
well that's the thing here right already
you've had
congresswoman ocasio-cortez accused ted
cruz
of trying to have her murdered all right
and now obviously
again that's the key quote where is she
where is she mace says she didn't hear
that
ocasio-cortez isn't exactly now backing
up that particular claim and to your
point also
she was not in the capitol building but
the cannon building which is about three
tenths of a mile away
from where the capital was being
breached
so i think the question here is is
alexandria ocasio-cortez somebody who
was credible
or somebody who has a history of lying
so i looked at her politifact file
and she was only fact checked ten times
which i find to be an astoundingly low
number but for the sake of this
conversation
eight of those ten times she received a
poor rating in terms
of fact check claims two times her
claims were considered half-truths five
times they're considered
outright false one time actually pants
on fire
so here we are again talking about her
rhetoric so much but no one really talks
about
alexandria ocasio-cortez's record in
congress
and the two major things that stick out
in terms of her legacy so far
is the fact that the green new deal was
introduced before the senate for a vote
and it failed 57 to nothing couldn't
even get a democratic vote
and amazon in her district the 14th here
in new york
she put on a public pressure campaign to
make sure that they didn't open up a
major hub
that would have bought 25 000 jobs and
150
000 average salary and that is gone now
for her constituents so i think more and
more we should be
looking at her performance in congress
and not so much analyzing her
performance
on instagram sean all right and and pete
let me ask you this the entire green new
deal
this this is the big push this is the
squad
nancy pelosi is intimidated by the squad
because she knows that
if congresswoman ocasio-cortez comes
after her and doesn't want her as
speaker
she'll probably be successful in that
effort okay
so we've got this whole group of people
over here but it's all based on her
belief that where the planet is doomed
in 12 years
unless we do the green new deal which we
also know to be
a predicate for all things radical
socialism
which is now being adopted and
implemented by joe
uh yes sean and the constant all of that
is hysteria
you need hysteria whether it's true or
not you have to
feel like the planet will end in 10
years you have to feel
like they were at your door to kill you
and in this particular case if
if comrade cortes identifies as being
under threat then we should take her at
her word in that sense
but she's almost using sean the uh
the fog of war defense right in the in
the minute in that moment i didn't know
what was going on
my sense was that i was under threat as
a result you need to believe me
my question is will the she then go back
and revisit all the police officers
she's called into question
who made tough calls in a moment that no
one else can identify because they were
there or maybe side with the mccloskeys
in st
louis who thought they were under
seizure or the trump supporters leaving
the white house
white house who felt like their lives
were under threat she was nowhere near
what was happening
yet her sense was her life could so she
shared it with the world all the
feelings and emotions that she has
we're supposed to take her at her word
will she ever
once left turn around the other way and
acknowledge that maybe some other people
have been in that situation too
no they use hysteria and emotion to
advance their causes to your original
question sean
climate change being chief amongst them
so they can shame the rest of us
don't worry about your facts and your
information i feel more i
care more than you therefore you're a
bad person
this what she did on instagram whether
she meant it whether it was true or not
is an extension of that kind of
perspective both powerful
uh analysis both of you guys pete thank
you joe concha thank you when we